after 17 hours of negotiations we have
an agreement wax it is definitely off
the table here is Akismet at mrs.
Prosser fellows non-canonical anomalies
virus this Aligarh he has put millions
of off following marathon sessions of
Europe group finance ministers and his
summit of heads of state agreement was
finally reached on the third bailout
package for Greece relief no doubt for a
country there has been teetering on the
edge of collapse but has it paid too
heavy a price what actually did Greece
get more pain more suffering alone
timidly grexit I mean what is this I
mean it's it's dead wrong in terms of
economic common sense
it's just ideologically driven
humiliation if people realize that this
that well tramping on democracy is it's
perfectly okay with in the European
Union the only winners of this thing
will be the likes of marine lepen
Nigel Farage etc reham died on that
billion oil overwrites the fur gang had
become by the NZ Thunder condition
hamby's no lung for six weeks and mrs.
mesquite yet some vital oxygen oil does
for comment accretion on Darfur for
Langley and on perform not skiing Liza
was not sinistra Minogue and Kip when
ascended sash nation's infantry armed
with them glide switched and dream let's
Nia a harsh line and Greek
responsibility also issued by other
conservatives it's one thing to have an
agreement after more than sixteen
seventeen hours of debates it's another
thing in executing what what has been
promised otherwise if it's only hollow
words it is in fact kicking the can down
down the roads if it is a real reform or
real execute if changes then they will
see a new future for the Greek people
away some so promises yet to be
fulfilled
I was so real strength we won the main
battle and so I think one of the lessons
coming from this weekend is that we need
more Europe we need mechanisms that
would be more integrated at the EU level
exactly for the reason that one country
who is going to be maybe
the first or creditor country is not
going to impose its rule to the others
Greek journey goes on there is a Greek
or they say that will go on on this on
this tune on this item for many years to
come but what we have seen now is a
relief for the time being
how long if people think that Greek
problem is solved and it has just
finished I would say just wait for the
next episode because I think is about to
start